et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Pierre Raffarin merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes ancien
Premier ministre président de l'ONG
leader pour la paix on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour
Emmanuel Macron a donc reçu hier plus de
200 m qui ont été touchés par les
émeutes chez les artsualiser un discours
de fermeté sa priorité c'est le
rétablissement de l'ordre il a eu le bon
message le chef de l'État je crois c'est
la bonne initiative parce que j'étais
pas tout à fait d'accord avec cette idée
qu'il fallait opposer dans cette période
de crise les mères à l'état et je pense
que c'était bien que on la République
avec tous ces acteurs avec les
responsabilités différentes des rôles
différents des responsabilités
différentes mais soit ensemble face à
cette crise et donc pense que c'était un
bon message que d'être ensemble
d'écouter les maires avec leurs
difficultés parce qu'ils ont été
vraiment en première ligne de cette
crise et au total je pense que le
président montre que la République
cesser se rassembler et priorité
rétablissement de l'ordre on est un peu
loin du macronisme original c'est un
discours de président de droite écoutez
on est dans une période de crise là pour
le moment on est dans une situation de
rassemblement où il faut faire face à
une station difficile d'abord je pense
que le point important c'est de se dire
que la politique n'est pas innocente
d'écrise la politique n'est pas
innocente des violences et donc il faut
bien voir moi c'est ma conviction depuis
longtemps quand la violence augmente
c'est que la politique recule et au fond
on voit bien que le discrédit de la
politique affaiblit le message politique
et je crois que le manque de respect de
la politique pour des politiciens pour
la politique et la première les premiers
de nos sujets il faut qu'on pour au
moins que le Parlement le Sénat est
assez exemplaire de ce point de vue là
mais l'assemblée donne le sentiment
elle-même de ne pas respecter la
politique or la politique a été inventée
pour lutter contre la violence donc si
on ne respecte pas la politique on
favorise la violence on risque de
trouver que l'assemblée ne respecte pas
la politique je pense qu'il y a des
insultes quand on joue au football avec
la tête d'un ministre c'est pas un
respect comment voulez-vous qu'on
demande aux jeunes de respecter le pays
si ceux qui sont élus pour leur
présenter ne respectent même pas
un langage directement à la France
insoumise je pense à la française bien
sûr et donc assez à cette cette logique
la politique ça devient de la polémique
ça devient de la provocation quand on
dit il faut pas donner de prénom aux
enfants parce que on les gens trop tôt
je veux dire on fait de la provocation
politique que cette provocation là c'est
pas un message de sagesse ce qui se
passe dans l'hémistique depuis le mois
de juin dernier et ce qui s'est passé
dans les quartiers la semaine prochaine
je pense que le lien n'est pas la direct
mais que le climat de non-respect de nos
institutions venant des institutions
elles-mêmes et quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave et que il faut
respecter les institutions moi je pense
que l'esprit des institutions les
valeurs des institutions mais aussi les
organisations des institutions donc
toucher à la République c'est quand on
touche à l'école quand on touche
au tribunaux quand on touche aux
policiers on touche vraiment à ce qui
était essentiel pour nous et ça je pense
que la République doit prendre un virage
aujourd'hui et qui est un virage de
fermeté pour montrer que on a des droits
et des devoirs je pense que le débat est
ouvert mais quand on respecte pas la
République on n'a pas forcément droit à
toutes les prestations de la République
à prendre ce virage de fermeté qu'il
affiche en ce moment je pense que
Emmanuel Macron est quand même un
président qui a eu à faire face à un
certain nombre de crises incroyable
quand on fera l'histoire on verra que
par rapport à ces prédécesseurs et il a
eu des citations extraordinairement
difficiles quand vous quand vous gérez
le covid-rendicante j'étais à la tête du
gouvernement mais ne pas savoir si les
écoles seront ouverts la semaine
prochaine c'est un problème majeur de
fonctionnement de la République donc il
a eu les gilets jaunes il a eu le covid
aujourd'hui il a ses émeutes et ses
émeutes on voit bien qu'elles ne sont
pas que françaises que c'est un mal
mondial des inégalités mondiales partout
on voit que les ça existe aux États-Unis
ça existe dans d'autres vies donc il
faut il faut bien voir que dans cette
affaire je crois qu'il y a pas que la
crise sociale il y a des inégalités il y
a on a besoin de cohésion sociale il
faut revenir à cette thématique
chiracienne de la cohésion sociale ça je
crois que c'est très important une
république elle doit avoir comme
première valeur la cohésion sociale mais
on voit bien qu'il y a une action
politique le débat est politique qu'il y
a des non intégrés de la République qui
combattent la République et c'est non
intégré de la République et il faut
faire en sorte que il puisse ne pas
nuire et c'est la fermeté qui est la
seule réponse je trouve Édouard Philippe
palab à bonne formule quand il dit les
émeutiers ne peuvent pas avoir le
dernier mot c'est ça qui est très
important c'est ça la fermeté ils
n'auront pas le dernier mot vous
soulignez que le premier mandat de
d'Emmanuel Macron et ce début de nouveau
quinquennat ont été marqués par des
mouvements violents vous situez les
gilets jaunes nous on peut citer les
deux périodes de contestation de la
réforme des retraites aujourd'hui ce qui
s'est passé en banlieue c'est de Soline
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron est
correspondable de ces de l'émergence de
vraiment violent qu'on n'avait pas vu
lors des quinquennat précédent où est-ce
que la société a changé et explique en
partie ces phénomènes je pense que la
société a changé je pense aussi qu'il y
a eu des fragilités dans la macronie je
pense notamment que le manque
d'organisation partisane j'étais à la
tête du gouvernement j'avais un parti
qui me soutenait qui était l'UMP nous
avions dans chaque circonscription un
responsable des dossiers retraite qui
était coordonnées par des parlementaires
à l'époque était François Baroin qui
était
Bertrand l'actuel président de haut de
France on était donc il paye son monde
et je pense que en termes d'organismes
je trouve que le parti n'a pas la
puissance que devrait avoir un parti
présidentiel je crois que c'est quand
même très important moi je donc la fin
des participes à théorisés c'est une
erreur pour vous je pense que je pense
que on ne peut pas gouverner sans parti
on a besoin d'un parti ne serait-ce que
pour vous protéger n'attend vraiment
pour vous nourrir des équipes pour vous
des idées pour contacter l'opinion en
permanence pour être en proximité mais
on ne peut pas gouverner un pays en
homme seul donc il est la cible de tout
seul parce que le gouvernement est peu
connu au total à l'Assemblée
parlementaires sont des visages nouveaux
enfin
moi je serais conseillé du président
quel est ton meilleur ministre et son
meilleur ministre tu le mets à la tête
du parti tu construis un parti un parti
qui te protège mais parti aussi qui te
ancre dans le dans le pays qui te quel
est son meilleur ministre je pense que
ce genre de fonction que je trouve que
Gabriel Attal par exemple a des talents
pour ça il y en a quelques-uns c'est lui
qui veut mettre à la tête de renaissance
je sais pas c'est pas moi de le dire
mais mon raisonnement aujourd'hui c'est
que la solitude du président fait que
quand tout va bien tout est bon pour lui
mais quand tout va mal tout est mal pour
lui donc c'est c'est ça il faut protéger
un premier ministre ça protège le
Président c'est une fonction c'est un
airbag un premier ministre il faut que
ça prenne l'écoute il faut que ça puisse
les encaisser mais il faut il faut un
président ça doit être protégé il faut
qu'il puisse se consacrer à l'essentiel
donc aujourd'hui on le sent quand même
un peu seul dans cette mobilisation
terrible aujourd'hui
à l'Élysée ils sont pas ressortis
vraiment ravis de cette réunion et on
voit bien la relation s'est distendue
depuis 2018 et la crise des gilets
jaunes ou Emmanuel Macron les a associe
à la sortie de crise comment vous
expliquer ces tensions récurrentes entre
l'Élysée et les maires plus il y a de
crises plus la tentation et la
centralisation on veut tout remettre
dans la cabine de pilotage et tant qu'on
l'a vu dans la crise de 2008 les plans
de relance tout ça c'est fait de manière
centralisée on a abandonné la grande
ambition de décentralisation ce sont les
crises qui conduisent à ça mais c'est
vrai dans tous les pays il y a une forme
de centralisation je pense que de ce
point-là il faut écouter le Sénat il
faut écouter il faut écouter cette
sagesse territoriale on a besoin de
décentraîner ça fait partie de la
paroisse c'est vous qui êtes à l'origine
de la dernière est-ce qu'il faut une
nouvelle grande loi de décentralisation
je pense qu'il faut transférer un grand
nombre de responsabilités aux
collectivités territoriales Emmanuel
Macron il a pas du mal à être
décentralisateur je pense que tous ceux
qui sont dans les crises même Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2008 un plan de relance et au
lieu d'avoir des contrats de plein avec
les territoires on fait quelque chose
dans la cabine centrale donc parce qu'on
veut faire face donc je pense que la
crise centralise et donc elle accélère
tout cela mais je pense que c'est une
erreur parce que plus l'état est dévoré
on est en congestion cérébrale c'est à
dire tout tourmente au sommet et le
sommet se paralyse il faut laisser un
certain nombre de liberté et notamment
au maire mais mais pas seulement les
gens avec de vraies compétences et les
moyens qui vont avec compétences il faut
que l'État se désengage d'un certain
nombre de choses quand je vois par
exemple Pôle Emploi on a on a
décentralisé une grande partie de la
politique économique aux régions mais
l'emploi ça reste la responsabilité de
l'État donc on laisse l'emploi avec ceux
qui sont dans le territoire en contact
avec des entreprises au contact avec la
dynamique territoriale donc de ce point
de vue là c'est assez simple il faut
écouter un peu le chou que le Sénat
aujourd'hui a une position très
importante pour dans cette crise être un
facteur de sagesse peut-être un facteur
de solution si il y a un jour un entente
entre le le bloc à l'intérieur du bloc
républicain je pense que c'est quand
même quelque chose de très important
pour qu'il y ait à la fois une forme de
sagesse de tempérance de mais de fermeté
sur les valeurs de la République
respectant
la République et donc quand on respecte
pas la République moi je comprends qu'on
puisse se mettre en cause certaines
prestations sociales le respect de la
République c'est une condition pour
avoir les bienfaits de la République
celui qui ne respecte pas la République
il doit sentir que la République ne le
respectera pas à au degré où il
souhaiterait être donc sanctionner les
parents je pense que les allocations je
pense qu'il faut il faut trouver les
choses à inventer et à des élèves est-ce
qu'il faut donner le permis de conduire
à quelqu'un qui brûle des voitures enfin
il y a des sujets qui vont se poser
jusqu'à suspendre ou supprimer les
allocations comme le demande des
républiques je pense que les
républicains de ce point de vue là en
raison de prendre un virage de fermer la
République en la respecte et là elle
doit se faire respecter et je pense que
il est clair que les émeutiers ne
doivent pas avoir le dernier mot
qui ont été prononcées en première
instance sont extrêmement fermes vous
vous les estimez suffisantes
je pense que je veux pas commenter la
justice je pense que je trouve que la
justice s'est mobilisée qu'elle aide
agit très vite et ça c'est très bien je
pense que c'est tout ce dispositif me
paraît clair
le policier et dans une procédure
judiciaire on est dans on est dans un
état de droit qui fonctionne faut
respecter l'État de droit mais ça c'est
je pense que le respect de l'État droit
le respect des institutions respect des
organisations des institutions ça fait
partie de l'équilibre républicain là la
crise semble s'apaiser après quelques
jours on voit la décrue se poursuivre
est-ce que vous diriez qu'Emmanuel
Macron a utilisé les bons outils pour à
la fois être ferme apaiser les choses
je pense que oui globalement il a il a
mené dans cette bataille là de sécurité
je crois le pilotage du pays avec
responsabilité il a l'une son voyage en
Allemagne c'est très douloureux mais
c'est responsable donc il y a des
initiatives qui fallait prendre
finalement était pas indispensable on va
voir mais je pense que il y a déjà des
procédures d'urgence qui sont engagées
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'état d'urgence
tel qu'il est présenté aujourd'hui c'est
un symbole politique donc je pense que
l'État d'urgent de la réalité d'urgence
elle est là quand vous avez 45000
policiers qui sont mobilisés pour une
nuit et ça veut dire qu'il y a quand
même une forme d'urgence qui est qui
s'exprime donc je pense que globalement
les choses sont gérées je crois que ce
qui est très important maintenant c'est
de bien voir la partie cohésion sociale
qui est à gérer c'est-à-dire les
problèmes d'intégration la suite de la
politique de la vie etc ne pas laisser
aujourd'hui s'installer l'idée que rien
n'est fait que rien n'a été fait combien
d'associations combien de rénovation de
tours ont été organ combien de
rénovation de logements ont été faits il
y a quand même beaucoup d'actions qui
ont été engagées donc c'était une erreur
de rejeter le plan Borlo lorsque
Emmanuel Macron a décidé de le faire je
pense que le plan Borlo avait des une
dynamique qui était intéressante avec
une participation des maires donc il y
avait un processus que ce qui était un
processus de coopération et que ce
processus s'est trouvé ainsi interrompu
une erreur politique de le jeter à la
poubelle vous voulez me faire critiquer
vraiment monsieur Macron en tant que
dans cette situation de crise je crois
que la critique ne sert à rien comme
comme Edouard encore Philippe moi je ne
critique pas les gens qui sont dans
l'espace républicain je ne critique pas
mes anciens amis des républicains je ne
critique pas mais l'initiative de
Monsieur Cazeneuve je ne sais pas parce
que à un moment ou un autre faudra qu'on
soit tous ensemble les républicains dans
l'équation qui est la nôtre on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est on est passé d'une
situation où il y avait plusieurs blocs
maintenant à trois blocs on a un bloc
d'extrême gauche un bloc d'extrême
droite et un bloc central le bloc
central faudra bien qu'à un moment ou un
autre il trouve une organisation pour
essayer de faire en sorte que la
République de parcours extrême centrale
a du mal à s'organiser aujourd'hui en
voyage discussion très compliquée avec
les républicains autour du projet de loi
immigration vous avez encore un espoir
là dessus j'ai toujours un espoir bon
j'ai un espoir de toute façon on peut
pas avoir des discussions qui
républicains avec le Sénat on peut pas
en discussions avec le Sénat avant les
élections c'est la toriales soyons prêts
pragmatiques il y a des élections
laissant les élections se déroulaient
après les élections on arrivera dans une
nouvelle phase pour le Sénat le Sénat
pèse beaucoup de républicains là je
pense qu'il faudra discuter un certain
méchant mais moi je pense que ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir de l'action dans
les quatre ans qui viennent et l'action
elle passe par une majorité donc si on
peut s'entendre sur un texte par exemple
immigration si on peut s'entendre sur un
texte décentralisation si on peut
s'entendre sur un texte bas salaire la
Renaissance sur ce d'un côté les
républicains de l'autre je pense qu'il y
a possibilité ça doit être un accord
entre Renaissance et les républicains
que vous souhaitez ou est-ce que ça doit
aller jusqu'à la ligne jusqu'à Bernard
Cazeneuve
moi je pense que la question c'est de
savoir les trois ou quatre grands textes
il faut avant la prochaine
présidentielle il faut un taxi migration
il faut un texte décentralisation il
faut quelque chose sur les bas salaires
c'est un peu déjà sur les bassins
Bernard Cazeneuve les républicains et
les macronistes
mieux ce sera je ne cherche pas à avoir
une coalition politique je cherche à
avoir une assemblée qui est capable de
voter les quatre grands textes qui
montreront au pays que il y a une
direction que la République française
c'est où elle va qu'elle a des valeurs
et qu'elle veut les défendre et qu'elle
voulait défendre avec la perspective de
cohésion sociale mais le respect des
institutions avec fermeté et donc cette
logique là je pense qu'elle doit essayer
de rassembler elle rassemblera qui elle
voudra mais je pense que ce qu'il faut
ce n'est pas se dire on fait un accord
politique si on choisit quatre textes
trois textes deux textes je ne sais pas
c'est à discuter qu'on choisit des
textes très importants pour les Français
et que ces textes là il faut les faire
passer il y a des injustices à corriger
il y a un certain nombre de choses à
faire et c'est important de donner des
nouveaux pouvoirs aux collectivités
territoriales tout ça doit être fait et
doit être fait avec ceux qui veulent
bien participer à cette logique ce n'est
pas la division des républicains on voit
bien que sur le projet de loi
immigration certains seraient en
discuter d'autres pas du tout on voit
bien qu'il y a des divisions entre le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale au sein
des républicains est-ce que c'est pas un
des points d'achoppement de la grande
coalition que vous avez le problème
décrit c'est que ça crée des divisions
partout donc il y a des divisions ici
mais il y a aussi des divisions à gauche
et aussi des divisions partout donc tout
le problème c'est de redonner une
dynamique redonner un leadership
redonner une perspective moi je crois
que le leadership aujourd'hui il se fera
par l'action et cette scène qui qui doit
être laction c'est de dire aux Français
voilà on a quatre ans devant nous il y a
trois quatre sujets qu'on va vraiment
régler et on va sur lesquels on va
vraiment s'engager je pense que dans un
jour de par exemple dans la
décentralisation qu'est-ce qu'il faut il
faut que les mers reviennent de faire la
loi aujourd'hui on a exclu les maires on
dit que les mers sont très importants
ils sont exclus de la loi ce qui peuvent
pas être parlementaires moi je pense que
le maire doit pouvoir être parlementaire
donc d'abord là on parle on parle de
plan rural la première des choses sur le
plan gras c'est que les mers ruraux
soient l'assemblée
il faut il faut revenir en tout cas à
les mers puissent être parlementaires et
mère parce que quand vous êtes députés
vous abandonnez votre commune même si
vous êtes encore adjoint mais ça va
tellement vite il a responsabilité c'est
celle du leader et sur ces épaules le
jour vous avez pu la responsabilité vous
pensez plus pareil vous en avez discuté
avec le président de la République ne
sort jamais arrivé oui et qu'est-ce qui
vous répondez le président est conscient
que il faut agir il est conscient qu'il
y a des choses qui sont à changer et
c'est vrai qu'il faut remettre le maire
dans la loi ça ça me paraît être une
priorité il faut remettre le maire dans
la loi je crois que c'est une idée qui
commence à être là assez largement
partagé elle est pas encore peut-être
majoritaire mais elle avance
correctement mais je pense que quand on
parle de ruralité les mers ruraux ils
peuvent plus être entendus dans la loi
c'est que c'est quand même un vrai
problème donc je ne dis pas qu'il faut
revenir sur le cumul des mandats les
conseiller régionaux les conseiller
départementaux tout ceci mais le maire
quelqu'un politique de la République est
vraiment l'essentiel même de la
République populaire
c'est la commune et cette république
populaire elle doit faire la loi sur les
discussions avec les républicains est-ce
que Éric Ciotti est un interlocuteur
pour vous Jordan dardella elle disait
dimanche avec sotti c'est Monsieur plus
il prend nos propositions et il en
rajoute encore
et moi je cherche le rassemblement donc
je vous critique pas avec ce en plus
très franchement j'ai eu des combats
politiques avec lui bon j'ai des
désaccords je suis dans le même
mouvement que Christian Estrosi donc on
a des sujets de discussion mais en tout
cas il y a pas un mur entre Éric Ciotti
je parle avec lui et je le respecte il
est chef de partie étaient élus c'est
quelqu'un qui faut respecter comme je
respecte Bruno je suis plus LR mais je
suis toujours ami avec Bruno Retailleau
donc je pense qu'il faut c'est que avoir
une une logique de rassemblement
aujourd'hui on voit bien
rassemblement est possible avec lui mais
bien sûr on a fait lui un peu on a vécu
ces 30 dernières années tous ensemble on
doit pouvoir vivre l'Avenir Ensemble
donc ce qui est quand même très
important c'est de savoir où on va donc
c'est pas se dire on sait on s'aime pas
c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait et si
on veut travailler ensemble sur
l'immigration sur votre travail ensemble
sur la décentraîne région il y a pas de
raison qu'on trouve pas des solutions et
donc le problème c'est qu'il faut
travailler ensemble donc je pense que
c'est clair que la période des
sénatoriales n'est pas une période
opportune mais il y a de la matière
philosenna il y a des possibilités au
Sénat je pense que le Sénat peut
apporter beaucoup de choses je pense que
les députés et l'air de remplir leurs
propres choix bien sûr mais je pense que
il faut que tous tous ces républicains
là au moment où la République est
attaquée il faut qu'on se dise que vaut
mieux qu'on travaille ensemble plutôt
que de laisser la République aux
extrêmes donc c'est un peu ça le choix
on laisse la République aux extrêmes on
travaille ensemble en travaillant
ensemble sans se rassemblement là vous
appelez de vos vœux cette grande
coalition est-ce que Manuel Macron peut
continuer à gouverner pendant 4 ans on
voit que le texte arctex a ses limites
surtout depuis le texte sur la réforme
des retraites est-ce que ça peut durer
je pense que ça peut durer bon il est
clair que dans la Cinquième République
le fait de ne plus être candidat est une
fragilité pour un leader politique je
l'ai connu quand Jacques Chirac a montré
qu'il ne n'était plus candidat Nicolas
Sarkozy est devenu ce que les Américains
appellent le comingman et c'est le
coming Man qui dévore un peu à un moment
c'était une erreur de de décréter que le
président pouvait pas se représenter une
troisième fois
qu'on a eu les déclarations de Monsieur
Ferrand etc je crois pas qu'il fallait
changer la constitution je crois pas
qu'il faille venir là-dessus mais je
pense que l'idée de dire un président
c'est une surprise pas il a du courage
il pourra faire des choses c'est
contredit par une notion c'est que le
président qui ne s'en prennent pas il
est plus chef de guerre donc les députés
les parlementaires vont chercher leur
chef de garde après donc il y a un
moment où les la République va penser à
l'élection d'avenir or l'élection
d'avenir le parc le président sortant on
n'est pas tout à fait acteur il est
acteur par son bilan mais il est pas
tout à fait acteur donc je crois qu'au
total je crois que c'est en effet une
erreur si vous voulez bon ma vieille
expérience d'élus c'est que une élection
pour un élu c'est comme un examen pour
un étudiant c'est un rendez-vous c'est
un bilan c'est un point si c'est une
ligne d'horizon c'est que c'est quelque
chose de très important et et être élu
et ne pas avoir d'horizon comme ça c'est
quelque chose qui est à mon avis
situation il faudrait qu'il passe le
tombeau dès maintenant un éventuel
successeur non je crois pas je crois
qu'il doit assumer son mandat tout ça
c'est à lui de préparer son rôle dans la
prochaine élection donc est-ce qu'il
doit choisir quelqu'un pour le moment si
vous voulez
pour le moment nous ne sommes pas dans
ce premier type politique moi je crois
que la problématique politique
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'action c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et surtout
l'adversaire c'est l'impuissance ce que
reprocheront les électeurs et notamment
tous ceux qui sont exaspérés par les
émeutes ce qu'ils n'ont reprochement et
ce qui responsarant à la République
c'est c'était d'aller si elle est
impuissante donc pour le moment c'est
l'action et donc il faut la définir
quels sont les trois quatre priorités
qu'on règle dans les quatre ans et il
faut pas se dire qu'on va faire tout et
le contraire de tout donc on travaille
on travaille aussi sur il est important
qu'il y ait des gens qui travaillent
pour le prochain quinquennat pour pour
l'avenir je crois qu'il y a une réforme
de l'éducation c'est important qu'on
puisse travailler donc il y a un certain
nombre de sujets qui sont très très
essentiels là-dessus moi je suis content
quand je vois des gens comme comme
Édouard Philippe qui travaille pour
préparer
l'avenir donc ça c'est ça me paraît
important mais aujourd'hui c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des quatre ans et
comment on sort de cette crise si le
président de la République était réduit
à l'inaction parce que cette coalition
devenait trop compliquée est-ce qu'une
dissolution serait évitable
je ne crois pas je crois que la
dissolution c'est une arme contre
l'impuissance donc si si
pression dissoudre pour lutter contre
l'impuissance je pense qu'il faut
trouver d'autres moyens qui a
dissolution
je pense qu'il faut trouver les moyens
de plutôt moi je pense que la des
logiques à l'allemand sont plus utiles
que des logiques de dissolution les
Français ils ont besoin d'autre chose
que dans corps des clivages politiques
qu'on voit dans les élections et donc on
aura des élections à leur terme j'ai
toujours été pour le respect des termes
d'élections donc la dissolution me
paraît pas une solution idéale mais
quand dans le cas de menaces
d'impuissance le président est seul
libre de ce choix merci Jean-Pierre
Raffarin merci beaucoup bonne journée
à vous Christelle on regarde votre une
le monde ne nous reconnaît plus c'est à
la Une de La Dépêche du Midi aujourd'hui
merci Christelle à la semaine prochaine
merci Jean-Pierre Raffin on passe au
club des territoires